If you could steal the heat from the sun-rich
summer and give it to the sun-poor winter,
you could be the Robinhood of the world’s
energy needs.
Hey sunbeams, Trace here for DNews.
Solar recently grabbed headlines when the
Department of Energy found solar power generation
employs more people than generating electricity
from oil, coal, and gas combined.
In part it’s because of construction, but
also because solar workers do way more than
just building solar panels… they also work
on thermal energy projects.
The sun provides enough energy in about one
hour to power the entire planet for a whole
year, and a lot of that is heat!
We’re actually pretty bad at leveraging
this free energy the universe gives us, but
scientists are working to capture more of
it!
For example, researchers from Switzerland
developed a new way to capture summer heat
and store it all the way until wintertime
by taking advantage of the chemical properties
of Sodium Hydroxide, or NaOH.
NaOH is a white crystalline odorless solid
that reacts with water.
When you pour water on a mixture containing
concentrated NaOH, it releases heat in what’s
called an exothermic reaction.
To control the exothermic reaction, the researchers
exposed the NaOH steam… allowing it to release
small amounts of heat at a time, just enough
heat to heat up a metal pipe.
A solar collector can help reverse this reaction
by evaporating the water leaving NaOH behind.
If water is added to the mixture again - heat
will again be released, and this back and
forth can be reversed again and again!
Right now, the NaOH system is still a prototype,
so we haven’t solved the world’s energy
needs just yet.
But the researchers are looking for industrial
partners to help commercialize their technology,
which they think could be used to heat homes
in the winter.
All thanks to chemistry and the sun.
As you know, solar energy isn’t constant.
In the summer, we get more heat than we need,
so we use energy to cool down.
Come wintertime, we don’t have enough heat,
so we use more energy to warm up again.
The most challenging and most important part
of solar energy isn’t just how to create
it: it’s how do you store it?
Not just because of a cloudy day, but a cloudy
season.
If we repeated this simple chemical reaction
all summer, using the sun to add energy, the
generated heat could be stored until needed
in the winter -- weaning ourselves off of
dirty fossil fuels… but how?
Batteries suck.
We’ve talked about this a lot.
They’re actually one of the worst options
for solar energy storage - mostly because
current batteries are limited in the number
of times you can charge them, they’re fairly
expensive, and the types of batteries you
would need for this application would be huge.
With a bit more chemistry and physics, you
can store the power of the sun in salt!
Most power generation facilities use heat
to generate steam and turn a system of turbines.
Seriously.
Nuclear, coal, gas, solar.
All of them.
Wind and hydro just turn the turbines with
something else.
The Abengoa Solar's Solana plant in the Arizona
desert uses over 3,000 parabolic mirrors to
heat water and turn their turbines, but they
also can focus the sunlight to heat large
insulated tanks of salt causing it to melt.
The molten salt stores the energy gathered
during the day, which can later be used to
turn turbines at night!
Unfortunately, this strategy can only store
energy for 6 hours.
To store energy throughout the year we’ll
have to get more creative -- like by putting
it underground, which is actually what the
Swiss researchers suggested for their NaOH
system -- a geothermal probe.
Today, one of the most common strategies for
seasonal solar thermal storage is known as
borehole heat storage.
This essentially uses the heat capacity of
soil to store large amounts of heat underground
for months!
It works by drilling an array of boreholes
from about 30 to 200 meters deep into the
Earth.
During hot summer months, the heat is transferred
to water which is then stored deep in the
soil and rock inside the borehole!
That stored heat can later be extracted when
needed and used for all sorts of things.
Italy, Germany, Sweden, and the Netherlands
all use these systems, sometimes seemingly
keeping nest eggs of heat under their houses
like a neighborhood of giant chickens.
The challenge with the borehole strategy,
though, is that you need access to drillable
land, and for most people, like those who
live in urban areas, that’s simply not an
option.
Hopefully, someday, with a combination of
solar thermal plants, geothermal and borehole
facilities, as well as concentrated sodium
hydroxide, we might get close to weaning ourselves
off of fossil fuels forever.
If solar energy is so great, why aren't we
using more of it?
You can find out by watching this video.
And let us know down in the comments what
your favorite type of energy generation is.
I really like nuclear, I know that's controversial.
Let us know in the comments, make sure you
subscribe and thanks for watching DNews.